what we're looking at here is a group of
linked scenes which
comes really at the
end of the first half of the film
when rose
has come to
marry george and has come to live at the
burbank ranch george to celebrate his
marriage has decided to invite the
governor uh to dinner and his wife and
his parents
which is an amazing stress for rose
class stress combined with performance
stress because
george
loves the idea that rose is going to
play piano for them
phil where phil has
proven his superiority in every which
way as a musician and
so it's in that environment that uh rose
is anticipating her performance this
evening
we've been building up this scene for
quite some time you know uh george has
asked rose to play the piano a lot of
psychological tournament between
there and and this scene
kind of building
building and building and building the
awkwardness and the tension um between
all these people in a way to bond and to
build the tension
we had quite a a long piece of johnny's
music called the prelude which has a
kind of percussive uh drive to it like
it's really building or creating or
moving to something
and i think that's something we kept
trying to do shot wise with ari and
myself like place rose alone you know an
isolator in
in the midst of the dinner party when i
first read this scene um
it was
definitely scary to think about how to
how to light this big space and have it
still feel dark until this point in the
film are very much daylight and and
candles kind of world and the book talks
about the burbank ranch the first house
in the valley to have electricity and so
yeah i built a light that would that
kind of
was a very big soft source to to make
all the reflections feel very big
painterly but luxury soft top light that
would cover everyone and then moving
over to the piano to go more into the
fire light and the little you can see
the fire light on on rose kind of ups
the drama a bit with this um
kind of very slight flicker that you see
present i remember some of the really
early conversations that we had um
myself grant and and jane was about the
windows in this
um in the house and i'm really glad we
went with the backdrops i did i think
that was yours grant rather than blue
screen or green screen to to actually
print photos that we took on location
and have them out the windows
yeah it was a they're never easy they
look simple enough and uh i think the
main thing is getting the horizon line
at the right height to
what the camera is you know and that was
sort of a key thing for us
um but we also we took the shots and and
there are things that we had to paint
out of the shots before we had them
printed
our um unit base for example and things
like that that um so
it's a it's kind of an old it's an old
kind of craft in a way these are
physical backdrops because you know
modern films do bump to um green screen
a lot these days but uh i thought it
gave us some real benefits and the way
that it was lit ari that because the
scene goes from
late afternoon through into evening and
you know you can see the light drop and
that the um
that wonderful sort of atmospheric kind
of feel to it
this scene was was super challenging and
i really love how it's come together to
you really feel for her in this from
that from the very outset what i wanted
to do is feel completely present in you
know where i was so i really did get
lost in the scene i also remember not
talking to anybody that day much because
i wanted the first thing to come out of
my mouth to sound like
you know you feel like someone who
hadn't spoken all day knowing deep down
that it's very unlikely that phil is
going to wash up and play a part but
there's just this like such a hope that
he can finally sort of step into
this new role is now has a wife and and
there's such a pride there that i just
feel like everything gets crossed and he
kind of just completely freezes and that
was excruciating as well and i remember
everything that we had for nothing in
the barn that amazing location even the
weather at times was just blessing us
with
a habitat and a connection to to the
story into this this character i was
trying to to honor and become
i felt very nervous about clinking
across that car park in furry chaps and
spurs and feeling like i was at some
kind of weird cosplay party um
and so i was really really trying to
hold on to what it was that i'd come
from in that barn
we talked about um
in the script you never saw that first
moment where rose drinks and we put it
in this scene yes i think that was very
very smart of you i kept saying that
maybe rose should be
sipping all through the scene because
it's so tense for her and you were
really really adamant that no
that's not let's make absolutely clear
that rose is not a drinker
um and let's just really highlight that
moment when she just
succumbs to that
first drink
[Music]
i'm so sorry
i can't seem to play
this moment is like crucial and totally
totally important
that to see someone
innocent and hopeful like rose be
humiliated is um
you know
just so painful
you didn't
play sure did practice a terrible lot
see you wouldn't think there's much
difference between a cinema pit and a
dinner party yeah i mean i i remember
being
anxious about the sort of
the very open volley of um
you wouldn't think there's much
difference between playing in a cinema
pit and a dinner party
and that that being the most sort of uh
opaque kind of
dig at rose whereas the rest of it is
like jane says it is a secret between us
the abuser and the abuse that's the
tragic thing about it
there aren't many moments where
george is really
present and witnessing
exactly what phil is doing to rose and
this was one where i remember talking to
jane i was just like i just don't
understand how it's not getting some
sort of a rise out of out of george it
was that was that was really tough the
difficult part was to shut down some of
these
natural impulses that i have that you
know seeing her little face it's just
like it's heartbreaking i mean it's true
please stop cuddling her and support me
[Laughter]
at the very end we were looking for
something to highlight this moment of
rose's isolation i think we actually
asked uh
johnny to design something for this
which he quite ironically or
sarcastically called
lovely
evening fighters
i suppose it's a
pretentious way of trying to have music
which is out of character and isn't what
you necessarily expect trying to get a
limited palette together and the
limitation was i had like one microphone
and these on these two string
instruments for
rose and her sort of social awkwardness
let's push it into
being inhuman in how it sounds and the
fact that it
kind of became a theme for rose and her
drunkenness and her confusion and that's
when it really connected i think as an
idea
this is a scene where
it's shortly after the first time pete
has come into a somewhat uncomfortable
contact with phil
where he he saw phil in his
sacred space and had been chased out of
it but it's it's i feel like the first
time from the audience perspective just
in the walk alone that
our judgments of him being
somewhat naive transmute into a
assertive nature
everyone was hooting and hollering and
teasing him the first time around
and then on his way back they're all
silent which i think is something
very powerful and makes them look very
silly and it's probably something that
experiences a lot everyone
ultimately has this
judgment about him at first but then
they're silenced by him
so
this is the beginning of at least for
pete selfishly speaking from from my
point of view where he begins to pull
back the layers
of phil it's sort of
also because of the way that you put it
together that long tracking shot where
it's so uh
unchildlike this this walk you know and
there's such like power and like you
said cody i didn't i didn't fully
register
as it did watching this time the silence
on that walk back but to be wide
and then he drops in and then to see
this
this person that's that's not cody maybe
there are aspects of it but this
innocence that you're like oh this is a
child
but then as the scene progresses
you know that that that that's also
they're both they're both playing a a a
game and a part here there's just so
much happening with both of you guys but
yeah
you know what what what phil
now you see
you get it
you call me phil
i'm gonna finish this rope and
give it to you and teach you how to use
it
sort of a
lonesome place out here pete
unless you get in the swing of things
thank you
phil
phil playing a role we haven't seen
before this sort of fake chummy
thing he's doing where we don't really
know what he's trying to achieve here
like and i'm not even sure phil knows
what he's trying to achieve i look
forward to hearing what ben has to say
about it but
um
what i think is really happening is that
he's just using his instincts he wants
to bring the boy closer he's going to
turn turn it around and also
for the
you know
to actually really stick the knife once
again and rose because now that pete's
arrived it's a real comfort to rose to
have in there and
phil i think gets the intuition that if
he can
change that and bring
pete close to him
and drag him away from uh rose that this
will be absolutely destabilizing for her
it will be like the final straw
but we don't really trust phil we don't
really know what his goals are and we're
not really going to know you know and
this is where the mystery begins where
the film
really starts diving into unknown
territory and we we can't be sure what
the ambitions are for either pete or
phil
from my perspective there were two
things uh
that were very immediately kind of going
on for phil the first was that he saw
an unexpected strength in the boy's
life
ignoring of
his mockery of his mocking i mean
and i think
the idea that he could see someone he's
very alert to the
the wolf whistles and the name calling
and
it's definitely something
i'm looking and so there's some kind of
uh
electricity to that moment um but then
it's all about the way that peter
responds that really flaws phil
it was really hard seemed to actually
add it to wasn't it pink
yeah really hard i think we spent more
time on this scene than any other scene
in the movie also we had so much
coverage of these extras who had been
growing their beards for like six months
to fit the part
it's also a scene with the most
uh people in it in the film like extras
wise and
and then just the dynamics and the
geography of the conversation that phil
and peter have is um really tricky
because where's them here and also how
much could we go to rose without kind of
before the dialogue would kind of
fit the uh between pete and phil would
just start to
you kind of really need to focus on them
while knowing roses watching so it was
just a really tricky balance to get that
i guess it's hard for young unlike you
to call an old fella like me just
playing phil
but first
i'll come and take a look at this
and i'm really in love with the fake
chumminess that uh phil produces hair
and that little trick which is sort of
so
ironic really where he gets um
people to lean in and call him actually
phil rather mr burbank you know
that
phil thinks he's in charge here or in
charge generally and you know what a
reversal there is going to be
the film has very restricted color
palette um kind of by design that we
wanted to keep everything in the
world of the ranch with these very dusty
dry kind of silvery gold browns of the
the leather and the um horses and the
cattle and this scene kind of presented
a bit of a
both a challenge
and an opportunity
to kind of would we break that rule um
and and have this abundance of green um
and and ultimately we've decided that
yes we should
um embrace it and and have this be a
kind of um exception this this infills
um
willowy glade uh it was quite a
challenge in the color grading this is
probably one of the scenes we spent the
most time on in the grade yeah the tones
of the trees
are different as well so look at the
grass here and
the trees and it's just like vivid green
it could be like a lot green sometimes
so
it goes through a lot of different
greens you could say through through
summertime we didn't have to um be very
careful with our grass
lawn
through there because
you know grass keeps growing and once we
claim that space is being where we
wanted to film um we didn't need to trim
it down but let it come away again just
enough to
make it feel natural and
uncut in a way so it always takes a
little bit of manipulation
with uh our greens team to be able to uh
make it feel natural but controllable
it's a very precise art as well the
braiding um
that each
strip has to be the same tension and the
same width i love hearing you say about
the the tension
the weaving of this all the equal parts
very equal each one with its precision
we ended up finding a quantity of the
tents and making quite a few of them as
well you know after scrutinizing a lot
of uh
research images of what these campsites
used to be like and what the
the kitchen would have been like and you
know where they cooked up all the food
and i really love george's thing too how
you're just going about doing the work
like bringing the uh
food down to the
the kitchen the uh camp kitchen and
the occupied
background
a lot of walnuts that
day thank you thank you very much